ve lo dico subito non voglio tirarmela
ma siccome tantissimi di voi mi hanno
chiesto di farvi vedere gli ultimi
acquisti
ve li faccio vedere borsa yves saint laurent 12 mila euro borsa dior 7850 euro borsa di prada
11256,7 euro balenciaga soltanto 8.760
euro jimmy choo
se non sbaglio 1.850.000 euro
perfetto far finta di studiare mentre
guardi la tv check bere dalla bottiglia check
fare la pipí check
fly me to the moon and let me play among the stars
let me see what spring is like on jupiter and mars
che bella persona che sei cos'è
hai avuto un'infanzia difficile la mamma
non ti diceva mai che ti voleva bene o
era papà che non veniva a vedere le tue
partite di calcio io vi ringrazio ma
bisogna fare attenzione perché la
bellezza è un'arma a doppio taglio
aiuta negli affari ma rende più
difficile il rispetto
quanti anni hai 31 non pensi di essere un pó vecchia per fare i musically é ora di
smetterla tu invece quanti anni hai 38 non
pensi che siano già troppi anni che non
ti fai gli affari tuoi